so the newest Kakarot DLC just released
and surprise they kept secretly fight
with Demon King Piccolo we've actually
known about this since just before its
launch when some folks began leaking the
fight online but it's an interesting
thing for them to keep secret throughout
the marketing for the DLC they only ever
alluded to the main tournament itself
showing only a small cutscene of the
Demon King Piccolo fight in the final
trailer so then why did they keep this
secret was it to keep people from
speculating on Demon King Piccolo DLC I
honestly have no idea maybe they just
forgot and that would be the most
Toriyama thing any game has ever done
what do you guys think